how did this ever become a trend let's
just tie a rope around our necks but
fantasy right so today I'm tying a tie
for the first time a man in a tie it's
like the best thing I don't know why
it's like a weird like large shoelace
thank you from your neck I think I can
do it I'll think it's that hard
I'm predicting that I'm going to fail
this miserably I feel like I should flip
this up first
oh that's why they do this how listen
the winds are not I thought that these
were each different knots but it's
actually all steps so this has to be I'm
doing this for a girl I'm doing it all
rocks no no I'm not I'm so now oh my god
I think I got it hmm I did it
oh I'd really like to try that over
again I do that move all the guys do on
madmen it's not that hard beep line I
messed up the ends and I'm just gonna
hide this one in my shirt
pretty easy give me a harder one this is
the Eldridge not yes and with the
Eldridge last night for some pain up in
the cocktail it has 15 [ __ ] steps and
you're gonna whip it around town like
this and through the loop made in the
previous step I made a loop the ties
don't wrinkle because this is ridiculous
keep this part roots it's all loose it's
not just why would I okay curious
I have like three more steps to go if I
just put my collar down no one
notice I look great the tide of him come
at me Eldridge what now this is a bowtie
I'm nervous for this one because it
looks really complicated anyone who
knows how to do this has my complete out
of respect eyes are not sexy you just
look like a penguin how the hell did we
ever come up with this as a society I
don't even know what that next picture
means you're looking more fingers oh
[ __ ] I've learned how to winged eyeliner
was that easy note Oh choking what okay
hell am i let's just say I did it it
looks like a bow thank you like Fred
Flintstone
but you'll notice that this is not
perfect it's an ascot this isn't a bow
tie at all I never knew how hard pee-wee
Herman had it definitely takes a lot of
foresight going into it but once you
actually try it it's not that hard
except for bow ties those are awful I
never want to wear another one of these
again and then who tie their tie on a
daily basis I salute you this is hard
next time I see a guy in 400 I'm just
gonna give him like five high fives me
like that was like really hard you did
so good it's really tight no wonder this
is the signature I'm home move